harmonie rafesthain est à la taille sur
sa parcelle ici elle est responsable
d'exploitation depuis janvier en cdi un
métier qui demande de la polyvalence
j'ai la gestion de quatre hectares 75 de
vignes principalement en chardonnay et
pinot noir je réussis la fonction des
vinifications période de vendanges
m'occupe des saisonniers traitement de
ces traitements travail du sol
vraiment tout ce qui englobe à ce qui
englobe la vigne à l'origine harmonie
était loin du monde viticole
mais après une reconversion
professionnelle et trois saisons dans
les vignes et de la passion a grandi à
35 ans elle a donc repris une formation
je voulais pas rester juste ouvrière sur
le tâche voulais vraiment aller plus
loin et puis pouvoir être polyvalente
temps en cave que en vigne est aussi le
tractoriste donc voilà je voulais avoir
vraiment un panel complet
le brevet professionnel a été décisif
son employeur la connaissaient comme
ouvrière mais rechercher des compétences
pour développer une nouvelle parcelle
dans la formation je pense que j'aurais
pu penser ça c'est clair
expérience dans le
dans le métier déjà pour gagner du temps
pour un recrutement vite bouclée loin
d'être la norme car le domaine recherche
régulièrement du personnel tout au long
de l'année
la manoeuvre est compliqué à trouver
la madame saisonnières après la main
d'oeuvre qualifiée comme on en a besoin
à moi à l'époque facile à trouver mais
en général non la forme et qui avec
l'augmentation de la taille des
exploitations les emplois à pourvoir
sont nombreux
en dix ans le nombre de salariés dans le
secteur a augmenté de près de 30% dans
les vignobles de pouilly 200 cerfs et
des coteaux du giennois